ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément loin de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
jeudi
aujourd'hui nous sommes en normandie et
plus particulièrement dans le perche
[Musique]
bonjour ça va monsieur le gilet jaune
oui tu va nous montrer ton jardin avec
les jardins d'éden à commencer par le
chien ça c'est le jardin du confinement
donc tu as fait ça pendant le
confinement la voilà temps d'amener
comme tout le monde même si on n'est pas
en appartement on est énervé de ce qui
se passe de voir tout ce qui se passe on
est on est pas bien comme tout le monde
bah moi j'ai nettoyé rangé et puis j'ai
fait un jardin en plus il n'est pas
immense jardin il fait quoi
500 m² 400 m² une rente à 250 mètres
carrés en plus les asperges ici les
années quand 205 comment on peut vivre
en totale autarcie vous êtes combien 3
on a fait mine est trop honda 1000
mètres carrés
honnêtement il faudrait deux mille
mètres carrés pour vivre correctement
notre sort ça nécessite un apport avec
un cochon je mange de la viande que
j'allais vrai intelligemment et sans
aucun produit
et puis un mouton voilà il nous manque
juste ça parce que après franchement on
peut s'en sortir
à quelque chose près tum on n'aura
jamais cette chance là par contre après
il ya des fois où comme l'a souligné là
il m'a donné plus de 80 kg de prune de
quetsches mais c'est quetsches j'en ai
ramassé pour moi 15 kg le reste j'ai
proposé et j'ai des voisins
intéressant on va mettre essayer de
mettre en place une forme de jardins
participatifs
c'est à dire qu'on a tous tous en même
temps et on n'arrive pas dans mon père
c'est complètement stupide si on pouvait
partager et ça va même au delà pour les
surplus pourquoi ils n'iraient pas sur
les gens qui vivent dans les hlm tout ce
qu'on a vu dans le vide enfermé et qu'on
paye et les légumes la peau du cul parce
qu'ils étaient inacceptables - on avait
déjà des premiers produits à cette
époque là et pourquoi ce choix de vivre
pratiquement en autarcie
quand tu commences à habiter à la
campagne peut être un minimum de respect
de la nature par ton éducation familiale
et cetera tu t'aperçois très vite qu'il
ya des choses à parfaire
quand on habite en campagne je vous
parlais des champignons quand je trouve
des tas de trucs dans la forêt et est né
il ya plein de choses à ne pas faire
campagne
après bah tu t'aperçois que homme âgé
des mulots ah ben je vais te faire de
longues études et alors on met des
produits là c'est bon tous les oiseaux
qui vont grignoter dedans ils sont c'est
bon le chien du voisin cash and awe
voilà donc on s'aperçoit très vite par
voie de conséquence qu'il ya des
conneries à ne pas faire quand on habite
en campagne pour les mulots les rats
pour le dire ben piégé tout simplement
avec la bonne vieille taper tel morceau
de fromage ça marche très bien faut être
patient c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
après bat monfils il arrive je suis un
vieux papa cas pas pu avoir d'enfants
j'ai cette chance à j'avais une fille
avant mais voilà il ya dix ans elle
ratera pas envie qu'ils mangent de la
merde
et quand tu penses à ton gamin tu pense
aussi aux autres mois quelque part
voilà de moyens c'est pour ça que je
suis assez pour ça que j'ai il faut
démontrer aussi sa façon de vivre
pour donner envie à un maximum de gens
faire des efforts dans ce sens là et au
moins va éduquer notre enfant le balade
en kabylie à faire manger ça ça a été un
élément moteur pour moi
voilà c'est pour ça que là j'ai des
trucs pour éventuellement faire de la
caille éventuellement faire du pigeon
tout un tas de bestioles
mais je vois là il mangera pas mais
mathieu n'a pas mangé de poulets du
commerce ne pouvait pas cher je
m'entends des puits
moi je croyais temps n'a jamais mangé je
suis assez bien placé pour connaître les
produits qu'on utilise dans les champs
par ma famille et c'est ça fait flipper
quand même je vous ai juste parler des
stoppeurs de croissance mais je vais pas
faire la liste les énormes après moi
joie quand j'étais gamin dans une classe
il y avait une ou deux filles qui
étaient un peu obèses
maintenant c'est devenu presque une
norme pour moi c'est des gens qui sont
pris en otage parce qu'on leur a donné
on les hommes plus ou moins obligé à
manger tout un tas de trucs avoir une
hygiène de vie lamentables quoi mais
voilà c'est des choses concrètes moi
j'ai vu voilà j'étais gamin j'avais 15
ans alors et 55 voilà ce que j'ai je
vois qu'on joue à plein de choses
concrètement les cancers du sein pour
les femmes
ça vient d'où tout ça non ce con mais ça
a été une époque mais je pense que
maintenant faut inventer autre chose il
faut apprendre à reus aller fumer des
choses comme ça sans revenir en arrière
il faut simplement remettre ça en avant
on à côté des techniques et même les
industries sont capables de faire des
produits de bonne qualité
c'est juste que ça rapporte un peu moins
si on regarde bien on voit mes poulets
me coûte plus cher que quand juste à la
production puisque vous acheter dans le
commerce le prix de revient il est clair
et encore je peux pas me permettre
d'avoir des aliments bio j'ai pas les
moyens donc
fait voilà j'ai de l'aliment résonner ce
qu'il ya aussi des agriculteurs
raisonnée mereiles réel par l'assaut du
label chez q en quoi ces conneries qui
servent à rien ça dépense de l'argent
pour rien vous ferez mieux de le donner
aux gens pour progresser simplement tu
la garder ton gilet jaune c'est oit tu
les as encore tj l'étendant à plusieurs
j'imagine un nom géant un gilet jaune et
l'eau s'est investi ce il ressortira là
actuellement il peut plus sortir mieux
voilà album respect des seychelles le
respect des salariés va chaire et stoppe
donc à la date du 17 avril et lycées du
17 novembre au le premier acte
j'aimerais bien pouvoir un jour avoir
une date de fin ça voudrait dire qu'elle
sait pour venir que
gouvernement notre société a évolué et
comprend un peu mieux en compte des
dérives qui actuellement sont
inacceptables et vous madame vous avez
manifesté aussi avec avec les gilets
jaunes
non c'est mon mari qui va avec nos fils
aimé vous avez l'aurait jamais porté
mais vous étiez de de tout coeur avec
eux enfin oui tout à fait les mêmes
convictions des pistes de gilet jaune
regarde a changé malheureusement non
vous êtes toujours vous sentez oublier
complètement pas entendu son esprit zen
pousser ça exactement oublier c'est un
petit peu un sentiment déjà personnel
parce que il m'arrivait d'aidé
les déboires à mon travail et
déjà quand on a fait trente et un ans de
carrière avec un travail qui m'a
beaucoup passionné on se sent mis au
placard
tout simplement parce qu'il ya une
personne qui attend derrière moi connu
deux hommes politiques et ses réserves
mais je le ressens de plus en plus la
justice et puis voilà en plus c'est de
la discrimination parce que c'est par
rapport à ma maladie alors que comment
dire on le dit invalides
alors que je sais pas je n'ai pas l'air
invalide donc voilà enfin il ya déjà par
rapport à ça aux emplois depuis 1997 à
la naissance de ma fille qui l'a pas
beaucoup principalement des jeunes après
quand je dis oublier c'est
c'est par rapport surtout à l'égoïsme
aussi en fait
enfin moi j'ai eu moi je suis je suis
très naïve donc tout le monde se moque
de moi chaque fois parce que on raconte
des histoires du droit je pleure
beaucoup
mais de joie et de tristesse par rapport
à tout ce qui se passe par rapport à
toutes les injustices et
et oublié dans le sens où bat justement
par rapport à l'expérience que je viens
d'avoir je suis extrêmement blessé et
déçu parce que j'ai tout donné dans un
métier que j'aime énormément qui était
responsable de l'urbanisme à la mairie
est en fête
et du jour au lendemain on vous dit avec
vous est invalide il va falloir partir
madame et je n'ai pas compris pourquoi
es tu
et voilà donc je perds beaucoup de
relations beaucoup d'amis je perds une
vie que j'ai carrément social ces chats
sociale et professionnelle
et puis et puis l'égoïsme des gens aussi
je vais dire on s'aperçoit que c'est
vraiment chacun pour soi mais aussi dans
tous les domaines et on
enfin moi je ne comprends pas c'est état
d'esprit mais m'ont juste façon je suis
trop naïve le sait on ne dit plus on vit
pas au pays des bisounours ça je le sais
depuis longtemps mais ce que je vais
dire c'est la vie c'est quelque chose
qu'on vous a souvent répété c'est pas 12
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que on a
le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre alors que ce serait là la vie est
si simple finalement en fait soit benoit
mais toi là bas mais toi copie si tu
peux de foot
regardez-moi à tous
[Musique]